au beau milieu d'un parc forestier de la
vallée de chevreuse la nature se laisse
écouter on est au coeur de la campagne
et donc du coup quand on sait et oiseaux
si on a de la chance est arrivé quelques
fois où elle et chevreuils passé là et
puis on essaie de vue sur le château
isolé au calme le château de dampierre a
rouvert son parc au public depuis le 30
mars il offre une balade familiale sur
un territoire à l'histoire royal
l'histoire c'est celle à famille de
luynes qui devient duc de chevreuse et
qui est partir de ce moment-là veut
construire le château avec jules
hardouin mansart qui permet bien après
cette famille d'imposer son pouvoir sur
cette vallée de chevreuse et d'y
recevoir la cour de versailles
un aménagement permet aujourd'hui des
balades en calèche en rosalie mon
voiturette de golf et même sur l'eau sur
les pas de louis 15
imaginez des chaloupes qui depuis le
château sont arrivés avec des
embarcations de part et d'autre et une
grande fête a eu lieu ici est donc cette
ce pavillon sur l'île est vraiment
extraordinaire
il faut qu'il soit restauré évidemment
mais il est vraiment extraordinaire
parce que c'est cette petite folie
opposé au milieu de l'île ma petite
folie
mon petit grain de fantaisie
surprise dans les hangars un ensemble de
cas des voitures hippomobiles sont
conservées cinq d'entre elles sont
exposées au public en attendant
l'ouverture prochaine d'un musée dédié
donc du coup on a exposé et bien
découpés de gala des calèches jusqu'au
break de chasse qui était tout le train
hippomobile pour la vie quotidienne des
ducs et duchesses de luynes au xixème
siècle le château de dampierre était
fermé depuis 2016 les yvelinois peuvent
de nouveau investir ces patrimoines et
1749 c'était toujours un moment en fait
très privilégié parce qu'on passait
vraiment ce moment à un pique-niqué
ensuite à jouer au football donc germond
des souvenirs comme enrichi de nouveaux
souvenirs qu'ils se construisent dans ce
parc en attendant l'ouverture du château
lui-même ses travaux de rénovation sont
actuellement à l'étude
[Musique]